pour vivre à calgary ces jours ci il ne
faut pas avoir peur du vide au centre
ville un bureau sur quatre est inoccupée
le joueur est content de lui cet espace
depuis plus d'un an il a vu n'est pas
plus réjouissante 18 à 20 étages vide
dans cet édifice complètement neuf
auparavant au centre ville 80% des
bureaux est occupé par des entreprises
pétrolières ou gazières mais avec tous
les emplois perdus
c'est assez catastrophique avec la
catastrophe c'est ce que tentent
d'éviter ces orateurs comme dominique
moussu ben voilà on va faire une petite
crêpe
on a favorisé la crêpe bretonne
un mail à
bon ça fait 17 ans l'habitat calgary
depuis la chute des prix du pétrole en
son chiffre d'affaires baisse de 15 %
chaque année on a perdu des clients
mais au lieu de venir mais dont 2 3 fois
par mois ont validé le plus qu'une fois
par mois parce qu'ils ont moins d'argent
parce que l'économie ne va pas bien ça
fait deux ans qu'on me dit que ça va
revenir l'économie ça va revenir
et puis je vois pas d'amélioration je
vous dise si jamais les pattes line ne
sont pas autorisés moi je vois pas
comment l'alberta on va s'en sortir quoi
rien à voir en tout cas avec les belles
années
moi je me rappelle des ddd business
lunch du business dinner avec 6 ou 8 go
mais ça consommer des bouteilles
exceptionnel quoi 500 dollars 400
dollars la bouteille de vin et puis ça
ça et ça y allait faux mais est ce qu'on
peut vraiment blâmer which la clé pour
les prix du pétrole qui sont bas non
mais bon est-ce que c'est ce que ça
valait le coup de changer les lois la
loi qui préoccupe le plus c'est la
hausse du salaire minimum 15 dollar
dollar
aujourd'hui encore davantage ses marges
de profit de mini croit que le
gouvernement néodémocrate de huit jours
note lee aurait dû attendre meilleur
contexte économique pour l'augmenter si
on continue avec cette politique là en
ce moment ça va pas marcher quoi il ne
sait pas encore pour qui il va voter
mais une chose est sûre ce ne sera pas
pour le npd
[Musique]
des gens sont prostituées avec la taxe
de carbone
cette grogne contre les politiques du
npd pierre fourny l'entente presque tous
les jours il est conseiller financier
pour les entrepreneurs à calgary
les gens veulent avoir de l'espoir d'un
changement souvent peut-être une canne
il leur donne l'espoir
oui mais selon lui ce qui aiderait
vraiment calgary c'est sortir de la
dépendance au pétrole
il n'est pas certain que les
conservateurs de jason kenny veulent
s'attaquer au fond du problème
on espère qu'à la leur à long terme il
va avoir des succès de se diversifier
alors une économie qui est un peu plus
pour seulement basée sur le pétrole
car même si bien des calgariens ont la
nostalgie des belles années
ça ne pouvait pas durer croit-il et la
crise aujourd'hui amène une réflexion
nécessaire
peut-être c'est le changement qu'on a
besoin pour se rediriger pas avoir
quelque chose qui est un peu plus
soutenables selon lui peu importe le
parti qui sera élu le 16 avril
calgary et doit s'habituer à sa nouvelle
réalité et si laurence martin radio
canada
belga